In the following videos, we're going to do an aside on information theory and
how it's used in data science, specifically with regard to feature selection.
The purpose of this video is to equip you with the necessary background
knowledge to use information theory as a tool in the future.
In the next video, we'll go back to building our inter Tweet time predictor, and
how we can apply information theory to it.
Information theory is a field of computer science developed by
Claude Shannon while working at AT&T's Bell labs to understand how to
send reliable digital signals.
It quantifies the notion of the amount of information contained in a message.
The science of information theory is a powerful tool used all the time by
data scientists to understand the relationship between parameters.
I want to give an overview of what information theory is all about and
how it's used in data science.